happy thanksgiving from all of us here  at good day las vegas heather what's  your meal of choice for thanksgiving ooh  i'm going with stuffing how about you  i'm all about the stuffing all about the  turkey all about the biscuits okay and  i'm eating your cranberry sauce okay  cranberries sharing is caring nate  what's your favorite thanksgiving food  i'm going with mashed potatoes with a  lot of garlic in them how about you uh  skip the garlic but i'll take the gravy  and all the pumpkin pie i can stuff in  my face  happy thanksgiving from all of us a good  day kiersten what's your favorite  holiday dish ooh  maybe brussels sprouts how about you  pumpkin pie oh that sounds delicious  happy thanksgiving from eight news now  hey fellas what's your favorite turkey  day dish pumpkin pie i gotta go gravy  love the gravy from our table to yours  happy thanksgiving  [Music]